[Musique]
donc les méchants ce sont les skrulls
et vous vous êtes une cri une lignée de
nobles guerriers héroïque noble guerrier
errant week
[Musique]
il a commencé le jour où elle a failli
s'achever
on a trouvé
j'avais tout oublié on a fait de toi une
des nôtres
pour que tu vivre plus longtemps
plus intensément
les héroïquement
et de voir
j'ai souvent des flashs
comme des souvenirs
quelque chose dans mon passé est la clé
de tout ça
vous savez le piloter on verra
[Musique]
c'est oui ou non sinon il n'en est pas
question eh oui
ce que tu veux savoir
[Musique]
ce que tu es vraiment
je crois que j'ai vécu ici
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous me cacher
vient de très loin
tu n'es pas aussi fort que tu crois
c'est hier
qu'un début
notre guerre je ne vais pas la faire
[Musique]
je vais y mettre un terme
oh mais que t'es mignon titre en toi
comme ça comment tu t'appelles atterri
je reviens